[موسيقى]
القصف يحيل منطقه روسيه لمدينه اشباح مع
تواصل الحرب في اوكرانيا سكان مدينه
شبكينو الحدوديه يعيشون حاله من الرعب وسط
ضربات على المدينه شبيكينو التي تبعد عشره
كيلومترات عن الحدود الاوكرانيه باتت جزءا
من خط المواجهه بتعرضها لقصف مدفعي بكثافه
غير مسبوقه الهجمات الاخيره سرعت اكبر
عمليه اجلاء عسكري في روسيا منذ عقود وفقا
لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز حاكم منطقه بالقرود
الروسيه اعلن اجلاء مئات الاشخاص من
السكان وتم نقلهم الى ملاجئ مؤقته في
الصالات الرياضيه بعيدا عن الحدود الانباء
الوارده من المنطقه الحدوديه تشير الى ان
الاسبوع الماضي كان الاكثر دمويه بالقرود
منذ بدايه الحرب نيويورك تايمز التقت برجل
اعمال في المدينه اشار الى ان اقليه فقط
كانت تعارض الحرب في بدايتها الا ان الوضع
تغير اليوم تماما
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقص
ص قياس وتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات